good morning good afternoon and welcome
everyone
thank you for joining us for our
presentation titled optimizing glycan
separations
and analysis by hplc it's my pleasure to
introduce you to lance casper
a technical specialist at agilent
technologies
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the q
a box our speaker will address your
questions following this presentation
please join me in welcoming lance casper
i will now
turn the presentation over to him
good morning everyone my name is lance
casper
and i'm a field application scientist at
agilent
my primary role is assisting customers
with the hplc analysis of biomolecules
so this includes proteins oligos
peptides and of course glycans
the so the main focus of this talk will
be on the hplc
separation of released and glycans
i'll give some background on the topic
i'll also discuss
some best practices for robust methods
and i'll talk a lot about method
development
and resolving critical pairs of glycans
glycans are a post-translational
modification that's present
on many proteins including many
therapeutic proteins
such as monoclonal antibodies glycans
are made up
of monosaccharide monomers that make a
branched polymer
that is connected by glycosidic
linkages and n-glycans specifically
are attached to the nitrogen
atom which is why they're called
n-glycans on
an asparagine residue in a particular
consensus sequence so the location that
a glycan
is attached to a protein may be
consistent
but there would be variability in the
structure of the various glycans
that are attached to that protein and
that could vary depending on
the culture that the protein is grown in
for example
so glycans need to be characterized for
regulatory reasons
and there's a lot of value to
characterizing your
your glycans it's important for safety
efficacy
and quality of a biologic
so different glycans some of them are
not naturally present in humans and
could cause
an immune reaction and other glycans
could
have an impact on the pharmacodynamics
or pharmacokinetics
of your therapeutic
so there's increasing scrutiny on
glycosylation
and it's really important to have a
robust method
for analyzing your glycans
in order to speed up your time to market
there are a number of ways to analyze
and glycans
and you can get information about the
glycan structures
on the intact level so with the glycan
still attached to the protein
you can also digest the protein into
peptides
and look at the glycopeptides
however you get the most information by
releasing the glycans from the protein
and that makes it easier to separate and
characterize without the interference of
the protein
and this is the the workflow that i'll
be discussing today
is release 10 glycans
the goal of n-glycan analysis is to
determine the structure
of all the various glycans that are
attached to your
protein or your therapeutic protein and
in addition to that
you would typically track the relative
percentage
of each glycoform and you can see from
looking at this chromatogram that these
samples can be
very very complex so separation
can present challenges
and the peak assignment can also present
challenges because these are
structures that use repeating monomers
so there can be isobaric
glycans that are difficult to
definitively characterize just by mass
back
so why do we release and label glycans
well there are a couple reasons uh
firstly when you label a glycan you
create a one to one ratio
where each glycan has one label attached
and this makes relative quantitation
much
more simple so the relative quantity of
each glycan is proportional to the
the peak area another reason is it makes
detection easier
so it increases the sensitivity
both by fluorescence and also mass spec
another advantage of labeling glycans is
when uh free release free release
glycans actually can
have two different forms of an alpha and
beta form
whereas when you attach a label it locks
the glycan
into a particular configuration so
you'll get a single peak
for each glycan and this makes of course
the chromatography
and mass spectra easier to interpret
um hplc it's a it's really sort of a
ubiquitous analytical tool
people are familiar with it it is you
know fast
and so this is a it's a very appropriate
method for
analyzing and glycans
so how do we accomplish peak assignment
so how
that would mean determining the specific
glycan structure
that corresponds to each peak in our
chromatogram
and there are a number of different ways
of doing this and
i won't go into detail on this topic
but i want to give you some an idea of
how this is accomplished
and one of those ways would be to use
known standards and compare things like
retention time with a known standard
to your particular sample
there are databases that
have basically retention times
and these are called gu databases or
glucose unit databases
it's a database of retention times for
particular glycans
and its relative retention times to
a a glucose unit ladder and i'll talk
about that on the next slide
of course mass spectrometry msms
and maybe uh
more time-consuming but perhaps the most
uh rigorous
is using exoglycidases
so this is sort of the sequential
sequencing
or removing each glycan one by one
to sequence your glycan and agilent
provides offers exo-glycosidases
we also offer men
a wide variety of standards and
libraries
so how does a gu database work
well this relies on using a dextran
ladder
so this is a ladder that has increasing
number of
glucose monomers and then you can
compare the retention times of your
samples
on relative to that ladder and this
would be
more consistent than the absolute
retention time
of your peaks and uh you can use this
concept
to help you with a peak assignment
but with some caveats
so when you assign your peaks a glucose
unit value
where they fall in relation to this
ladder
that that will not be consistent if you
change any method parameters
such as temperature gradient
and therefore in order to use a database
to do peak assignment it really needs to
be done
with the exact same conditions and the
exact same method
that was used to create the database and
even things
like system uh you know delay volumes
could potentially make that less
reliable
there are occasions when peak assignment
is
less challenging and can be accomplished
just by comparing your sample
to a known reference standard
such as you know if you're developing a
biosimilar
that has comparable glycosylation
to an innovator therapeutic
it may be pretty uh maybe
easier to determine what the major
glycoforms
are and it would more come into play if
there's
new unrecognized peaks
there's a lot of choice in the labels
that you can use for glycan analysis
today i'll be discussing two different
labels
2ab is the first one and this is a
really well established glycan label
and people like this label in part for
consistency with historical data and
it's
been used widely for a long time
there are advantages to newer labels and
the newer label that i will be speaking
about
is called instant pc
which is developed by etulent which or
formerly prozyn acquired by agilent and
this label
offers advantages in terms of
speed of sample prep but also in
sensitivity so it increases the
fluorescence and
mass spec sensitivity
this slide shows a comparison of the
response for different labels
and as you can see 2ab is
provides far less response than
more recent labels such as instant pc
it also shows here a comparison of
flora ms which is a a waters label
whereas ins that has comparable mass
spec
sensitivity but instant pc provides
a better fluorescence signal
i won't go into the detail of the
process of labeling glycans and doing
that sample prep
but i did want you to be aware that uh
the the sample
process has come a long way whereas in
the past this could be
a one to two day procedure
it's now possible to do the sample prep
and and
releasing and labeling glycans in
potentially less than one hour
so there are a number of different modes
of chromatography that can be used
to analyze released and glycans and
these include hylic
anion exchange and reversed phase
those have all been used for analyzing
and glycans however helic really has
some
uh big advantages and am i hilic columns
have become the the industry standard
for
released and glycan analysis amide hilic
columns
are able to separate glycans roughly
according to their three-dimensional
size with larger
glycans being more retained
and hillock also allows the retention of
polar analytes that would be difficult
to retain
on a reverse phase column so polar and
charged analytes
the mechanism of helichromatography
which stands for
hydrophilic interaction chromatography
is
often described as the reverse of
reversed phase
so instead of a reverse phase separation
where you begin with a
lower amount of organic in the mobile
phase and increase the
organic in order to elute your analytes
uh hydrophilic interaction
chromatography retains polar analytes on
a polar stationary phase
and in and this and the strong solvent
is
actually water
so and then the distinction between
hylic and normal phase
is really that hylic is sort of using um
water and acetonitrile is the mobile
phase instead of organic
mobile phase components
chromatography columns are continuously
advancing and being refined and agilent
offers
two chromatography columns for glycan
analysis
they're both hylic amide columns
one of them is a superficially porous
2.7 micron
stationary phase whereas our other
column
is a 1.8 our sub 2 micron
stationary phase that offers the highest
resolution
uh with the trade-off of having more
back pressure
and these high resolution columns can
allow in
some circumstances and for some
applications the ability to have
very fast high throughput runs um
in the in the area of five minutes
and this won't be appropriate for all
samples
but for some some applications that you
know this is
this is certainly possible we typically
recommend
people beginning with our sub 2 micron
column
assuming they have instrumentation
that's that would support that
and this column can be used on
a 600 bar system
so it doesn't require a
uh plc or 1200 bar system
the 1.8 micron column uses a 300
angstrom pore size
and this allows access to the pore
structure
for larger glycans so it often
could give a little bit better
resolution for large glycans
there's a little bit of different
differences in selectivity
so there are certainly times when those
selectivity differences
could make it more advantageous to use
the 2.7
micron column and the 2.7 micron column
was
also has lower back pressure so if you
have
older hplcs in a qc environment
this could be a more appropriate column
the mobile phases recommended for glycan
analysis
using hilic chromatography are ammonium
formate
typically between 50 millimolar and 100
millimolar
and this is at ph 4.4 put to ph 4.5
for mobile phase a and 100 acetonitrile
for mobile phase b
and of course mobile phase a increases
throughout the gradient
and so why do why do we use ammonium
formate uh it's
used for the high solubility in
acetonitrile
it all the ph keeps the acidic glycans
in the charge state
and makes them easier to separate and
a ph of 4.5 is
very gentle on bonded silica phases
so it's a good ph for the column
stability
and it provides enough buffer capacity
so when a protocol calls for using 50
millimolar ammonium formate
at ph 4.5 what exactly does that mean
because there are different ways of
preparing buffers
and those can impact your chromatography
if you're not consistent so some people
use solid ammonium formate
however it's very hygroscopic and could
create
more and one unwanted adducts for ms
so our recommended method is to
make up one liter of 0.5 molar formic
acid
and adjust that to the ph 4.5 using
ammonium hydroxide so formic acid and
ammonium hydroxide are readily available
in high grades and high purities so we
recommend
purchasing high grade fa and store this
in the refrigerator and then you can
dilute it as needed
for your mobile phase and that allows
you to change your mobile phase
often and potential and
eliminate the possibility of for example
microbial growth in your
mobile phase
we recommend using a system suitability
standard
that is appropriate for your particular
sample
so this is some examples of different uh
you know types of glycans
such as high metals glycans or acidic
glycans
or something that'll be more
characteristic of a
monoclonal antibody and you can use that
standard to
check the system and column performance
over time
agilent offers a wide range of standards
and libraries so these are individual
standards that can be labeled and or
unlabeled
and we have multiple labels and
libraries such as
an igg glycan library
a first step to your hylic
chromatography method
is column equilibration
in comparison to reversed phase billet
columns take a long time to equilibrate
so at the end of each method we
typically recommend
having over seven column volumes
of mobile phase to re-equilibrate the
column
and it's important to know that most
methods or many
methods are not first run ready so
you may need to do a few injections and
make sure that
retention times are stabilized
before continuing your analysis
here we have an example of a helic
gradient that can be
used for the analysis of released and
glycans
and i would describe this as a somewhat
more complex gradient
there is shown here in the dashed line
a an alternative that is a simplified
linear gradient
but i think it's important to look at
the complex gradient
in order to discuss the tools
to maximize resolution and do
method development so in in our gradient
we are beginning with an intentionally
higher percent
b and the purpose of that is
when you inject a sample if there is a
lot of water in it
you run the risk of injecting a sample
in a stronger and a strong mobile phase
so it's important to
have a high percent be at the beginning
of the method
in order to prevent a quick illusion
and improve peak shape for strongly
eluding samples
and then you quickly drop the
[Music]
amount of organic and begin a
shallow gradient for small neutral
glycans
so glycans are going to separate
predominantly on the bases of size
with smaller glycans eluding first and
larger
glycans alluding later and then charged
glycans like acidic glycans
being being retained even longer
after a shallow gradient to get them to
maximize the resolution of the small
neutral glycans
we can leave a we can move to a steeper
gradient
where resolution is perhaps easier to
separate the
large and acidic glycans at that point
you would drop the flow rate i mean you
would drop the
amount of organic in order to do a wash
step
with 50 water just as in reverse phase
you would
you know raise the amount of organic to
wash the column
we're washing the column in a high
amount of water
and the percent
the percentage of water on acetonitrile
will
impact the viscosity of the mobile phase
so a lot you know if you have a high
amount of acetonitrile
it will be lower viscosity than if it's
50 water and 50
acetonitrile so if that impacts
the back pressure you can drop the flow
rate
for this portion of the gradient in
order to
maintain a reasonable back pressure and
this could allow you to use
something like a sub 2 micron column
on a 1260 or 600 bar instrument
after the wash step you move back up to
re-equilibrate the column in a
higher percent b so a high amount of
acetonitrile
and again we mentioned that it's
important to do a long
uh lung wheel collaboration or do seven
column volumes
uh to re-equilibrate the column and
in order to speed this process up it is
you can
increase the flow rate
this slide shows that we have some
flexibility in developing methods
that could be longer to maximize
resolution
or shorter to increase throughput
and all of these example methods were
used were run using
a 600 bar instrument and two of the
methods we're using our
cell 2 micron glycan
amide hillet column
many customers look for a standard
method
or an agilent recommended method to use
with our
hilic glycan columns and so we've
published
many methods both in app notes
and also in manuals and these methods
can give
customers a place to start and may work
well
for not many samples without the need
for much or any method development
here are some app notes that i recommend
that contain standard methods for doing
n-glyc release and glycan analysis
i'll also highlight the one at the
bottom which is a 2d
lc analysis so one way to maximize
resolution of n-glycans
is they can be analyzed using
two-dimensional chromatography
for example using anion exchange
chromatography
to separate glycans based on their
charge state
followed by a hillock method
some helic columns are more retentive
than others so when moving a method
from one column to a
a different column it can it can be
helpful to use these rules of thumb
where you would
increase the percent b to compensate
for the difference in retention
characteristics
of the different columns and that way
you would maintain
uh your glycans to be in the same
retention time window so
our sub 2 micron column is
less retentive than our 2.7 micron
column
and we also have a competitor amide
column
that is even more attentive
i will also point out that there that
again moving from different columns
you'll see changes in selectivity
so for example uh using these these
particular
gradients uh the competitor column is
having a coalution of man5
with a g0fb
also switching labels uh will change
some labels are uh more attentive than
others
so if so we recommend if you're
switching from a method from 2ab
to our more recent instant pc label
to decrease the initial percent b by
about two percent
and then carry that decrease throughout
your gradient
here we see a number of isocratic runs
where we increase the concentration of
acetonitrile so at a low concentration
of acetonitrile
the peaks allude quickly in three
minutes
whereas at higher concentrations they
elude later
the important thing with looking at this
is we can see how the concentration of
acetonitrile
selectively changes the retention
of different glycans so the high metals
glycans the mann 5 and the mann
6 are being retained
less at the higher concentrations of
acetonitrile in relation to the rest of
the
complex glycans in this sample
so we can we can see that at the bottom
chromatogram
the mono6 is actually coaluting with g1f
whereas it was not coaluting
in some of the other isocratic runs so
we can use
the gradient to impact selectivity and
get
resolution of critical pairs
another strategy for resolving critical
pairs
is to alter the mobile phase
in this case by just adding two and a
half percent
methanol to our bottle b
are acetonitrile we were able to achieve
resolution between the mano 6
and the g1f peaks
different labels will also have
differences in selectivity
so in this case using our instant pc
tag rather than 2ab allows us to solve
the
issue of g1f and mano 6 colluding
or g0f and mouse 5 coaly coaluting
so with our instant pc tag these
common and often coaluting or critical
glycans are are well resolved
another option to improve peak capacity
and get better resolution of your
labeled glycans
is to move to a longer column so
in this case we move from a 150
millimeter column
to a 250 millimeter column using the
same gradient
and we can see that we are getting a
much better resolution of some of these
peaks
it's also possible to modify the
gradient
to match the p the retention time window
of your previous method and still get
better resolution by taking advantage of
the longer column
we have the our poor cell 2.7 micron
columns
available in 250 millimeter length
um our sub 2 micron column
is not currently available longer in a
longer length than 150 millimeter
but i have known um of customers that
will
that can use more than one column in
series
uh in order to maximize resolution
so you could use two of the subject
micron columns in series to
also increase resolution
another pair of glycans that may coelute
is a g2f and g1 s1f
and we found that by moving from 50
millimolar
ammonium formate to 100 millimolar
ammonium formate
these two glycans are separated
so the cons the buffer concentration is
another way of
altering cell activity when doing method
development
for uh released glycans
we typically recommend using 100
millimolar ammonium formate
as a starting condition to give the best
peak shape
and taking advantage of the strong iron
pairing
especially with our with our instant pc
die
and another recommendation is
if you're using an fld and a mass spec
you can split the flow with three
quarters
going to waste after the fld
and one quarter going to the mass spec
and this can reduce the chance of
damaging the
fld flow cell
one strategy for quantitative glycans
if resolution can't be obtained is to
use the relative mass spec
signal for each glycan
to assign a percentage of the
fld peak area to each glycan
so that would allow you to estimate the
the quantitation of coaluting structures
in fact instant pc labeled glycans
the mass spec result response
is correlates very strongly with
fluorescent response and it's
it's not recommended for quantitation
but it does correspond closely
we have some best practices and
suggestions for preserving the lifetime
of your helic columns so if you store
the helic column
in the t0 element so the
ammonium formate the column acidity will
increase
over time and this will actually
strip the bonded phase the amide bonded
phase off the
silica stationary phase
and this leads to neutral glycans
increasing in retention whereas acidic
glycans
due to the more silent activity with the
bonded phase being gone
will actually decrease in
retention because there's a sort of
repelling force between the negative
charges
so it is tempting to store the column in
the t0 element
for greater convenience so in your
starting conditions
and our columns we have shown that they
could be stable
for about six weeks under those
conditions
but for the maximizing the lifetime of
the column
we recommend that you flush the column
first with water
and then flush it with 100 acetonitrile
to store the column if it's going to be
if it's not going to be used
for any longer than a couple days
and that will reduce the chance of
retention time shifts in your peaks
so column lifetime will also be impacted
uh by
exceeding 40 degrees celsius temperature
so going up higher temperatures can
increase
performance and slightly and
it can reduce the back pressure but
it should be avoided especially working
with
acidic glycans because it will reduce
the lifetime of the column
when troubleshooting hplc methods for
glycan analysis
one thing to keep in mind is that metal
contamination
can impact the retention
of your acidic glycans so
it doesn't it doesn't show up too often
but and we do have ways to address this
so we have a bioinert
lc that has no metal in the sample flow
path
and this can be useful for many
biomolecule applications
where the analytes are metal sensitive
but this
is it's not required for glycan analysis
so we have two recommendations for
essentially passivating your system
to reduce the interaction with metals
in your flow path we have a
sort of a short passivation procedure
listed here with flushing the lines with
50 mm
or sodium pyrophosphate dissolved in 100
millimolar
ammonium formate adjusted to ph 7
and doing mixed with 10 acetonitrile for
one hour
and you of course remove the mass
spectrometer from the
flow path but agilent does have a unique
product which is a
deactivator additive and you can add
this to your aqueous buffer
and this will uh passivate your your
system
using the as you as you work and using
the mobile phase
an issue that is important to pay
attention to when using hillet
chromatography
is your sample matrix so if you inject
a large sample in water
you are injecting a sample in the
strong aleutian
[Music]
phase so this will cause peak tailing
and poor chromatography or even split
peaks
so in order to avoid that we recommend
using one microliter injections and in
that case you can use
100 water or if you
need to inject a larger amount to get
more sensitivity
we recommend diluting your sample
in organic such as acetonitrile
we can see from these chromatograms that
the five microliter sample in water
gives much worse tailing than the same
five microliter sample in diluted with
acetonitrile
again for our instant pc labeled glycans
one microliter injection and 100 aqueous
is okay
for larger injection volumes we actually
recommend for instant pc
label glycans not to dilute in
uh acetonitrile alone because it can
cause
uh xylated glycans to precipitate
so we recommend diluting in a one-to-one
uh
volume ratio of acetonitrile and dmf
and um diluting to to a concentration
of about 75 percent
of organic
i want to share with you some recent
work that we've done
with the coronavirus spike protein
so this is a highly glycosylated protein
that is used by the virus to infect
cells
and as you can see it's it's a complex
sample
but if you are working in this area and
you
are looking for any
feedback or consultation
we definitely encourage you to reach out
to us
to discuss our glycan solutions
in addition to agilent's products for
n-glycan
analysis such as chromatography columns
sample prep enzymes
standards we also offer services to
support
and glycan analysis including lcms
with glycan peak identification using
standards and exoglycosidases
to confirm glycan peak assignments
so if you are under time constraints or
are new to glycan analysis
we can partner with you and help you
develop
methods and often there are those are
methods that you can
then bring in-house using our products
this concludes my talk on hplc
analysis of released and glycans
and i believe there is some time for
questions
thank you lance for that outstanding
presentation
we will now move into the live q a
portion of the presentation
and as a reminder please submit your
questions via the q a box
let's get started so lance our first
question is we normally need to inject
larger amounts of samples
between sample injections do you have
any suggestions for column wash
and regeneration to retain the column
performance
um with our with our affiliate glycan
columns
you're typically not washing off these
sort of um
irreversibly bound things that build up
on a column the same way it
would happen with a reverse phase my
main suggest
the the lifetime limitations on these
columns there's more
a function of the bonded phase stability
but they can get clogged so my
recommendations would be to
definitely filter your samples and
you can use inline filters
and we also have guard columns so for
all the for both of our glidecam mapping
columns
we have the little five millimeter guard
uh guards with the
guard cartridge hardware uh so that
could definitely extend the life
um i don't recommend we don't recommend
that the columns uh be
flipped around and back flushed they're
they're meant for
a particular uh flow direction so we
don't
recommend doing that
great now lance you mentioned that a
labeled released glycan
is more likely to have one form upon
analysis
is there any advantage to being able to
detect both forms
um i i yeah i i believe what what that's
referring to
is the the label locks the sort of
um three-dimensional configuration of
the glycan when the glidecam is released
from the protein
it has some sort of play in it and the
and
the labeling it locks it it locks it so
you're going to get a single peak
but there's no value in um looking at
both those peaks you're
you're you're you're you have one glyph
hand there
so it's just using the label makes
analysis easier
so what are the pressure limits for your
two glycan columns mentioned
the the pressure limit for the sub g
micron is 1200 bar
and the pressure limit for the
superficially porous 2.7
is 600 bar wonderful thank you so much
for that
uh looks like we have time for a couple
more questions
so can you use gu values for peak
assignment
if glycans are not well resolved with
the standardized method
uh one possibility that you can
do is if you are able to resolve your
glycans
with an optimized method you it is
possible that you could collect that
fraction
and then re-run that glycan on a
standardized method
that is the same as what what's used to
create the
gu database and then you then that
that gu value would be more reliable
and um informative in terms of peak
assignments
but you can't you can't uh have a you
can't change the method
and use gu values um
and expect you gu values to not change
perfect thank you so much for that
clarification and it looks like we have
time for
one more question and uh this looks like
it's going to be a
a couple part question so did you repeat
the experiment of comparison
of the different labels so procainamide
rfms
and instant pc or did you just um
extrapolate a previous result for the
procainamide
um so the difference the the data where
we looked at the
signal intensity with the various labels
i i didn't i mean i didn't generate that
data my myself
um but as far as i understand this it's
not extrapolated
from previous results uh this was
yeah a de novo experiment
and lance i think we might be able to
squeeze one more in so how is the sialic
acid recovery
using the sub two column
um as far as as far as i know the
sciatica
acid recovery uh there is no issues with
that we've
i haven't seen any uh issues with
recovery of cyanic acid using that
column
thank you again lance and thank you to
our audience for your outstanding
questions
we hope you found today's presentation
to be informative and
insightful this presentation will be
available for on-demand viewing
but don't miss out on the other valuable
valuable presentations on our agenda
please visit the event presentation
schedule in the auditorium
thank you again for your participation
and until next time
bye-bye